Todo comenzó con este salto en el metro
de Santiago que resultó en el estallido
social más grande de la historia de
chile durante semanas millones de
chilenos Se tomaron las avenidas para
exigir al gobierno del ex presidente
Sebastián Piñera mejoras en Salud
Educación vivienda pensiones tres años
después Muchas de sus demandas siguen
desatendidas así como la búsqueda de
justicia y reparación Para los 33
muertos y más de 400 heridos con
lesiones oculares la mayoría a manos de
las fuerzas de seguridad todavía
mantiene múltiples deudas en primer
lugar porque respecto al esclarecimiento
de los hechos y a que haya Justicia La
verdad es que el panorama es bien
desolador tenemos una situación de mucha
impunidad de las 10.831 víctimas que
denunciaron haber sido objeto de algún
tipo de violación de Derechos Humanos
durante ese período la revuelta social
también derivó en la exhalación de una
convención para la redacción de una
nueva constitución para reemplazar así
la Carta Magna impuesta por los
militares durante la época del dictador
Augusto pinochet la misma que hace un
mes y medio fue rechazada por el
electorado el no ganó con el 62% de los
votos el estallido social expresó y
trajo consigo mucho dolor y ha dejado
enormes secuelas
no vamos a permitir que sea en vano
no podemos ser los mismos como sociedad
después de esta experiencia no podemos
cometer los mismos errores ni quedarnos
arrinconados en nuestras cómodas veredas
en el tercer aniversario algunos
manifestantes volvieron a las calles
también se movilizaron unos 25.000
uniformados mientras la promesa de un
nuevo acuerdo social sigue en el aire y
el descontento Hacia El Ejecutivo
chileno aumenta